you just heard country music star Luke
Combs Smash Hit of Tracy Chapman's far a
fast car it is burning up the music
charts but not everyone is enjoying it
the left-wing media attacking the song
over race The Washington Post is calling
it success quote complicated and say it
is quote clouded by the fact that as a
black queer woman Chapman would have
almost zero chance of that achievement
herself in country music
it's a completely ridiculous idea fast
Carr was one of the biggest songs of the
80s and early 90s and here's the kicker
Tracy Chapman says she's happy for Luke
and is honored by the track
all right you know given the fact that
artists have been singing each other's
songs for decades doesn't this show that
we're really coming together whereas the
left wants to show division and racism
wherever they can that's exactly how
what I thought when I first read the
article first of all I I still reject
this idea that these major newspapers
need to capitalize black and white and
because what they do is they find a way
to figure out a way what's a way to that
to create some outrage so that we can
make some money by getting people to
divide it against each other put this in
the title and then everybody's clicking
on it and they drive traffic but they
look so ridiculous at the Washington
Post because Tracy Chapman didn't want
to be on the country charts back then
she was at the pop charts and she was at
the top of the pop charts and
I can't imagine the Washington Post and
say isn't this cool this white country
singer likes this song so much that he
covered it and he gave her credit and he
gets she's getting more royalties and
she's getting more money like that could
have been the decision there's lots of
songs as you said gone back and forth
between races back for a long time and
we're all better off for it because
usually the covers are giving the
original artists some very good credit
the other thing is this is my little
fact that I found out about Tracy
Chapman so she was born in Ohio her
parents got divorced when she was four
years old her mom bought her a ukulele
and she was learning to play that and
guess where she thinks she was inspired
to write songs
Church
all right you know what Jesse given that
Combs version is generated at least a
half a million dollars in global
publishing royalties uh and the book
going to Chapman uh and it seems that
Tracy Chapman herself is very very happy
that Luke Combs is doing so well with
the song you know it's a good thing to
help her raise her profile for new fans
yeah pay me the money
but Harold was just saying he wished
someone would sample Taylor Swift that
is good to be back at the table
Greg talks about this all the time and
editor assigns a reporter to right click
bait and then the five producers scour
the internet in the morning yeah oh
there we go we got him on another one
just headlines about the music industry
white flight how Aerosmith made Run DMC
Walk This Way
hit the Beastie Boys album you're
probably an anti-semite I think one of
them is Jewish Taylor Swift the Karen of
pop and my final one from the post if
DeSantis is elected Elton John won't be
allowed to marry I found those after a
simple Google search these people are
way down the rabbit hole I was a Tracy
Chapman fan growing up yeah I had a
cassette tape judge I didn't know she
was black I didn't know she was queer
you're allowed to say queer they'd said
as long as I say it respectfully which I
did and then when I found out a couple
years ago I was like great who cares if
Dylan wrote a song that was good I'd
Groove to it who cares you know Greg
too would you chair dance chair dance to
it the amazing part of it Greg is that
Tracy Chapman is someone who has pretty
much always wanted to be in private she
doesn't like a lot of attention and
combs's version gives her privacy but
also recognition yet the Washington Post
ironically is doing her a disservice by
race baiting and using her as a talking
point to create an issue well you know
it's complicated
that's what that's what the writer
always says when they they don't want to
they have no actual angle it's
complicated look let's be honest here
we're bearing the lead it's a terrible
song oh come on
let me speak okay let me speak it's a
terrible song and I think people at home
right now are going thank you Greg thank
you not only is it repetitive and has
absolutely no rhythm it glorifies the
deadly risk of speeding you know how
many people listen to fast car and then
immediately said you know what Chicks
Dig Fast Cars I'm gonna get one and then
what happens dead I did some research
too Jesse did you know that according to
my research Auto fatalities pre Terry uh
Tracy Chapman and post Terry Chapman
chapter four thousand percent and all of
it according to the journey of effective
studies
is why they were all due to Tracy
Chapman and uh but it goes back to right
the race filter that people use now uh
that that that uh writers mindlessly put
it on and it the race colored glasses
force them to sing Everything where
there's no race they see it and then you
got the editors that go like they can
take any story you know Sports uh food
comedy needlepoint and just tack race
onto it and you get a story done this is
all just a this is not real there are no
there's no news going on in the
summertime that's the problem that's why
we're like this story is so hilarious
because we don't have any but the editor
should be fired is it no better you
should know better Jennifer rubin's
editor should be fired
it's a universal language the universal
language music is my my high school
basketball coach who quoting the great
Prince and basketball coach he said tell
me what I'd say coach I'm wide open he
goes forward good Shooters are never
wide open great music great music is
going to always be copied it's gonna
always be covered and if if Tracy
Chapman I thought her comment should
have selled it off for this young this
young writer look I mean the the Beatles
the Stones The Allman Brothers Clapton
everybody covered the great blues
artists the great Muddy Waters the great
T-Bone Walker the great Bobby Blue Bland
this is what music is about in America
and if we have to racialize this I think
the only reason that that that for Tracy
Chapman or anybody would be upset would
be if they weren't being compensated for
their work and I agree I'm happy to give
Taylor Swift it's good to be back around
the table whenever she wants to say
so after
up hey everyone I'm Emily compagno catch
me and my co-host Harris Faulkner and
Kaylee mcaneny on outnumbered every
weekday at 12 p.m Eastern or sets your
DVR also don't forget to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page for daily
highlights